مرحبا لم يكن مسلسل طاش ماطاش جماهيريه
مطالب بالعوده بالجديد الجمهور كان مكتفي
مبدئيا بفكره عودت ثنائيه ناصر القصبي
وعبد الله السدحان للعمل ليس ذلك وحسب
والعوده بعض النجوم ممن كانوا مبتعدين
خاصه يوسف الجراح وفهد الحيان وغيرهم الا
انه كان ينتظر ان يعود العمل بقصص وحكايه
وقضايا تشبه ما يعيش اليوم واقع مختلف
تماما بالطبع عن الماضي وهو ما كان فريق
العمل ليحرص عليه طوال فتره التحذير يعني
هذا اكثر شيء يشغلنا انك انت شلون شلون
ترجع الجو
العام حق طاش شخصيات بافكار البسيطه هذا
اكثر شيء كان شاغلنا
يعني واتوقع ان حنا يعني المسنا هذا الجو
يعني
رحنا الجو
خفيف
حاولنا نركز على الجو الشعبي
[موسيقى]
صدقا كاني في حلمنا انا المكتوب على الورق
صعب صعب والحمد لله تيسر
بنسبه مشاهده عاليه اردنا ان نعرف لماذا
تم الناس بالعمل لهذه الدرجه وما رايهم
بالجزء
الجديد نزلنا اليهم وسالنا حميده لهم نصر
القصوي وعبد الله السدحان
ويعني احنا كنا مشتاقين لهم وبعد غياب
طويل بصراحه عوده جدا جدا جميله اسعدت
اتوقع مو بس الشعب السعودي الخليج كامل
هذولي يعني
جيل الطيبين وذكرات مره حلو
صغار
وشفنا بدايتهم كانت قويه السنه هذه
ونتمنى ان شاء الله يمتعونا في الحلقات
القادمه
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات